pommier jambon qui aimeront et effet
100% chayer 100% du berry son jambon
biologique
là il à l'amandier elle en est très fier
et pour cause il est totalement produit
dans cette ferme
les porcs sont nés ici ils ont été
nourris avec des aliments bio produit
sur ses terres elles vont aussi des
conserves de patti des rillettes et de
la viande fraîche ou fabriquent tous
louent même de a à z
donc il n'y a pas d'intermédiaire est
prestataire autres donc on est capable
de lui expliquer précisément quand est
ce que les choses ont été faites comment
à partir de quelques cochons à partir de
quelle poule et ça permet vraiment de
rassurer le consommateur est d'avoir une
traçabilité en termes de bio sans faille
ces produits sont vendus dans les
magasins biologiques par le biais
d'associations soit le marché et un
vente directe il y a moins
d'intermédiaires et les prix restent
donc abordable à quelques kilomètres de
là jean françois vincent et éleveurs de
porcs et de brebis lui aussi les temps
bio et ce depuis la fin des années 80 on
en a eu marre de produire toujours plus
voilà on voyait qu'on produit phare est
toujours pas dire plus pour plus de
kilos de viande pour avoir le même
revenu aux plus faibles on sait d abord
faut faire de la qualité il n'y a pas de
solution quoi la viande bio reste
difficile d'accès selon un récent
sondage 9 % des français interrogés ne
mange pas de viande bio car pour eux il
est compliqué d'en trouver
pour jean françois vincent le
consommateur doit pouvoir en trouver
partout y compris dans les grandes
surfaces
lorsqu'on ouvre au rayon boucherie que
je vois dans une grande surface
spécialisée ou bien sur une boucherie
qui est constitutif
tout de suite on a des consommateurs qui
sont contents et on a débouché qui est
avant qu'ils arrivent à vendre toute la
bête quoi pas simplement les morceaux à
griller alors que la consommation de
viande baisse dans son ensemble la bio
elle se porte bien les ventes de porc
boeuf veau ou moutons ont progressé de 2
% l'an dernier